machu picchu just reopened for one  taurus who waited  seven months to see this this is jessie  takayama  taking in the sites of peru's most  famous ruins on saturday he has been  stranded in peru since march  when he traveled to the country with  dreams of touring the world wonder  he arrived just as the pandemic hit and  peru put strict coven restriction in  place  so takayama's initial plan for a short  stay finally paid off  after officials approved his very  special request to walk machu picchu  before he  heads back home wow isn't that cool i  love that they did that i always wanted  to go there but go him that he stayed  that long and now that they're making  arrangements  they made arrangements for him to see it  alone that is he's a boxer so he was  training young people to box while  waiting for his opportunity  they finally let him go very beautiful  private tour in the end seven month wait  but a private tour  very cool